ethical hacking often called white hat
hacking involves authorized
professionals who deliberately seek Out
Security vulnerabilities in computer
systems networks and software these
experts are also known as penetration
testers or Security Professionals work
to identify and rectify potential
weaknesses in an organization's digital
infrastructure unlike malicious hacker
who exploit these flaws for personal
gain ethical hackers operate with
permissions and the goal of
strengthening cyber security ensuring
systems as resilient against cyber
threats their work is pivotal in
protecting sensitive data and preventing
cyber attacks in our interconnected
World in this Digital World security of
digital content is the point of concern
and so ethical hackers have a huge
demand in the industry the average
salary of an ethical hacker is
$122,000 per year so if you are dreaming
to pursue career in ethical hacking then
you are at the right place as simply
learn offers best cyber security courses
in the industry in collaboration with
topnotch universities to make your dream
come true these cyber security courses
and certification programs equips you
with the expertise to protect networks
computers and data against the
unauthorized intrustion enhance your
capabilities with this cyber security
training which sharpens your skills in
identifying vulnerabilities thring
attacks and reacting swiftly to critical
situations over an year of experience is
preferred to take up these courses find
the link to the courses from the link in
the description box so before we move
ahead consider subscribing to Simply
learn and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from us so let's take a
small overview of how and why ethical
hacking tools are important ethical
hackers successfully carry out ethical
hacking practices with the help of
ethical hacking tools here is why
ethical hacking tools are important
ethical hacking tools are crucial for
primitively identifying potential
security weaknesses within an
organization's digital infrastructure
these tools play a vital role in
detecting and understanding potential
threats and methods that malicious
hackers might employ to compromise
systems they assist organizations in
ensuring that they are to security
regulations and compliance standards
that are often essential in various
Industries by uncovering vulnerabilities
ethical hacking tools help companies to
mitigate risk reducing the chances of
costly security breaches and data loss
these tools also facilitate the
preparation of organizations for real
cyber incidents by simulating attacks
testing incident response plans and
enhancing Readiness so let's move ahead
with this video and understand the top
five ethical hacking tools for 2024 the
number one on the list is 40 45 web
inspect 45 web inspect is a powerful
tool in the Arsenal of an ethical hacker
or security professional it plays a
crucial role in assessing web
applications for vulnerabilities
ensuring they are secure and resistance
to potential threats this tool developed
by micr focus focuses on web application
security and provides a wide range of
features and functionalities to uncover
and mitigate potential security issues
the price which is approximately
$229,450 includes hp's provisions of
both trans security and virus protection
the next we have is nmap nmap employed
in the practice of ethical hacking
during the post scanning phase stands
out as an exceptional hacking software
tool originally a command line utility
it was subsequently adapted for Linux
and Unix based operating system and
today a version of nmap is also a
available for Windows nmap short for
network security mapper functions as a
ENT tool for discovering host and
services on the network effectively
constructing a network map this software
boasts an array of features that Aid in
the exploration of computer networks
encompassing host detection and the
ability to identify operating systems
and Maps flexibility extends to the
script extensibility for advanced
vulnerability detection and it can
dynamically adjust to Network conditions
like congestion and latency while
conducting scans on number three we have
is nessus nessus is renowned as the
world's most famous vulnerability
scanner and was developed by tenable
network security this network
vulnerability scanner is highly
effective at identifying critical flaws
on a wide range of systems nessus is
capable of detecting the following types
of vulnerabilities unpathed services and
misconfiguration weak password including
default and commonly used ones and
various vulnerabilities within the
system nesus is available for free and
is particularly recommended for
non-enterprise applications on number
four we have is cane and able cane and
able and Os password recovery tool is
offered by Microsoft its functions
encompasses retriving Ms access password
employing Network sniffing techniques
and revealing password Fields decrypting
encrypted passwords through methods like
dictionary attacks brute force and
cryptanalysis attacks moreover cane and
AEL is available for free through open
source downloads on number five we have
is Kismet Kismet is a Top Choice ethical
hacking tool primarily designed for
testing wireless networks conducting
wireless land hacking and War driving it
excels in passive Network identification
packet collection and the detection of
non- beaconing and hidden networks
through data traffic analysis kmet
functions as a sniffer and wireless
network detector offering compatibility
with various wireless cards and
supporting raw monitoring mode key
features of gmet hacking software
includes its compatibility with Linux
operating system such as entu and
backtrack with limited applicability on
Windows system in the phase of
escalating Internet Security risk
employers are increasingly in the search
of adept and certified ethical hackers
who have completed courses like
certified ethical hacking course the
objective is to to the fraudulent
activities and identify theft
historically end users have often served
as the most vulnerable entry points
through which cyber criminals exploit
even the most robust defense systems
recent times have witnessed several
major corporations reporting
significantly security breaches ethical
hacking tools play a vital role in
helping organizations pinpoint potential
weaknesses in their online security and
thus Safeguard against the data breaches
don't wait start enhancing your skill
sets today so here we wrap up top five
ethical hacking tools for 2024 if you
have any queries add it in the comment
section below and our experts will happy
to help you if you like this video
consider subscribing to Simply learn and
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from us thanks for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs and Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here